yes I got engaged on the ring so he's
off to a roaring start okay I pick
congratulation thank that's been
wonderful that's one of the greatest
moments of my life yeah congratulations
yeah thank you very much et was with
Brad Pitt and Gwyneth Paltrow just after
their engagement in 1996 the two met on
set of the crime thriller 7 and ended
their engagement in 1997 I take the
institution of Larenz extremely
seriously everybody there are no
divorces in my family and and in his
either so you know we've been together
for quite some time so it was this is
not a rash decision have you come up
with a formula and how you find time to
be together yeah actually we haven't
it's been working out really great we're
just not doing movies at the same time
so I finished my last film great
expectations in October and then went
with him to Argentina while he did seven
years in Tibet and was there most of the
time with him and then he's gonna have a
break while I do my next one and then
I'm gonna take a break while he does it
so you know you really need to do that I
think in order to have a relationship
you know it's too difficult to be
separated it really is and back then
Gwen wanted a lot of kids so brood of
like 12 hey Sarah why you're like your
dinner first 12 kids yeah I guess gonna
be a dad with a lot of kids any idea
what kind of well I better be a good one
huh